I'm joined Now by a superstar new pack
the author and columnist Sir Simon
Jenkins talk to your contributor Esther
Krakow and Royal biographer Tom Barr
welcome to all of you
um Simon
what do you feel about this last 24
hours what impact does it have on you
it's very difficult to separate one's
own personal feelings and what what you
sense than the nation of the whole
Fields I mean it was expected
um it was predicted to put it mildly
um you do feel that some of the Earth
has changed yeah there's no doubt about
it I mean I was walking in the mall this
afternoon and it was Eerie yeah people
were all they looked a bit zombie-like
as they wandered round but um this is an
extraordinary event it's the end of the
queen it's a long Reign more interesting
in many ways I think it's the beginning
of a new one and what did you think when
you watched Charles tonight the first
big speech King Charles III I mean apart
from anything else having to do this
when you've just lost your mother after
having your mother for 70 odd years
that's a hell of a thing to have to do
anyway
um how did you think you did well having
just heard Lynn trust his speech right
I'm a friend he won
um it was a genuinely moving performance
I mean he had a long while to prepare it
I know um but it really it was moving I
have to admit I thought he did very well
yeah I did Tom Royal biographer a big
book out at the moment about Meghan
Markle who we haven't seen uh in the
last 24 hours the word is she was going
to go up to Balmoral with Harry
yesterday and people decided it wouldn't
be a good idea and so she stayed back in
London which is of course where where
Kate was as well
um that interplay itself I'll come to
that in a moment about what he does now
Charles the king about his two sons he
were war and indeed his own relationship
with Harry who got one line in this
speech which was a perfectly nice warm
line but it was one line and William he
lavished a lot of praise and titles on
what did you think of the speech from
the position of our new monarch as one
of the subjects well I was alter the
boat for a child's four years ago right
and uh my book is very critical of him
because he had a rather checkered career
until uh recently not only many scandals
and financial impropriators and things
like that I think in the last couple of
years he's reformed himself dramatically
he has
removed the controversy from his life
he's become far more serious far more
sober and I think that reflected today I
mean he just he knows that his past is
acting as a deterrent or a potential
deterrent from him being accepted as a
as the Monarch and everything depends on
public acceptance so I think he did his
best today and he did it very well to
reassure people that he wasn't going to
interfere that he would not be
controversial that Camilla was an equal
partner that William was the next in
line I think on the other hand he also
wanted to emphasize that he was a
transition Monarch he wants to make his
mark on History yes he wants to oversee
the changes but then he won't be vocal
he won't interfere what should he do I
mean what is the The Logical smart move
for a new monarch in terms of taking the
monarchy into a a new era what should he
be doing well I think what he's got to
do is what the queen did which is just
to smile and encourage people and appear
independent and impartial and appear at
uh well that's the same isn't it I mean
no no until now until a couple years ago
he was constantly making a speech no no
I understand that as Prince but I mean
in terms of a monarch if that's all he
does is mimic what his mother did is
that enough given all the speculation
about the monarchy its very future the
Rumblings we've seen on some of the
recent Royal tours does he need to do
more yeah so he's a queen he can't
follow the queen I mean clearly it's not
an act he could follow it's a different
era uh he's got to somehow find a way
which the the reign of Charles III will
be seen in history as a transition
moment that in the end we are a
different country and all the rest of it
and he symbolizes the change how he does
it will be you'll choose the right
venues they'll make the right speeches
he'll make the right appointments he'll
go on Royal tours which will improve the
image of Britain and in the end as well
he'll make sure that William supports
him we've got the front page of the time
this has just dropped I think which is
another a very powerful front page
they've all been great the fleet
Street's been fantastic in the last 24
hours God saved the king and in a way
this shows he doesn't it immediately
yesterday whole front page of the times
the queen who had just died today God
saved the king and Esther I was I was
very moved and struck by when he walked
around outside Buckingham Palace came
down he must have been when he was
driving down thinking I hope this goes
well this Walkabout because if there was
any kind of negativity then it could
have been a really big problem for him
you know that they can plan all they
like for the Queen's death in terms of
logistics what you can't plan for is the
public reaction and I was really struck
by how warm it was I was just the crowd
were very multi cultural old young black
white I mean people from all over the
world and they were all very pleased to
see him and Camilla and they were very
warm they began singing God saved the
king they even began singing The New
National Anthem with the new lyrics yeah
I mean he was very warm I don't think he
was he was very
joyful there was a warm Spirit about him
which I was I was I think is very
commendable you know considering 24
hours beforehand he just lost his what
do you think he has to you're younger
than the rest of us yeah I mean
um I think what do you think he's got to
do to try and be relevant I think his
problem is if it was King William the
other young people would be oh great
it's one of us right my daughter's
reaction she's 10 was oh he's really old
yeah Disney King Charles and she she's
10 because she thinks I'm really old but
you know he is in his 70s he's not a
young Monarch at all his mother was 26
yeah very very different set of
challenges one of which has had to be
relevant to young people I think this is
the thing because I was saying my
generation doesn't really understand
continuity and community in the same way
that sort of the generations beforehand
did and those those are the qualities
that I think endeared the queen
um to much of the country as well I
think what he really needs to focus on
is being a continuity
um King and really again being impartial
which he said in his speech each and
slimming down the royal family which he
made very clear but also kind of
embracing the change that comes with
these turbulent times I think that's the
only way he can appeal to my generation
and I think also you know focusing on
instilling a sense of community and Duty
because those were the legacies of his
mother and I think that's something
that's generally very missing in my
generation but I would love to see you
know that come back Simon have you ever
known a time in your lifetime where it
things have felt quite so jittery the
reason I say that coming out of a pretty
devastating pandemic with all the
Fallout from that a new war in Europe
and with no idea how that's really going
to play out you've got a financial
crisis of Epic Proportions with her list
trust the new prime minister pledging
100 billion yesterday barely got noticed
in the storm of the Queen's Den you put
all this together it's unbelievable
series of challenges for the Prime
Minister for the new king and for the
country well I mean I remember the 70s I
don't know driving across badassee Park
and just seeing great areas of London
blacked out right and we were two day
weeks we've got the rubbish piling up in
Leicester Square did he feel worse than
that yeah it felt pretty bad there
honest and also inflation was 20 right
now I mean you you've got to be very
careful you don't just play the old card
but um it looks pretty bad now I agree
uh it looks pretty bad largely because
the the Ukraine war I mean because of
the rocketing up in in fuel prices yeah
and I honestly think that'll come to an
end within a year or so and it'll sort
of seem all right again reverting to
King Charles I think what's interesting
though I sort of disagree with with
John's lately I think he's got to make a
transition he's got to be in charge what
would you want him to do do a new
monarchy which he he said he's he's
talked about it privately in the past
quite a lot he he needs to be just come
right down to um the king in the air
that's the royal family not all this
cluster of of Entourage he hasn't got he
doesn't need four palaces in London he
doesn't need four homes in the country
the the the the image of extravagance
and um sort of Splendid celebrity I
honestly think those are over now yeah
he's got to get the thing down to into
simple terms but the other side of the
coin I think is going to be he is not a
silent man he has got very strong views
and I helped him with his architecture
speeches once yeah he's got very strong
can he keep his lip button he will not
he will keep his lip button in public
but the trouble is he's going to be
seeing I can you imagine him meeting Liz
trust every week I mean he's got there's
going to be a nightmare in that room
yeah and I know he always I I shouldn't
say this but it'll always be the but I
know I think you're right I'm gonna stop
himself